hi kevin o'leary hair standing the
middle of switzerland actually i'm just
out of a little village called neo just
outside of geneva halfway between
Genevan lowes an you know what I love
about Switzerland everything smell the
air smells like money this is what sonq
read about this country everybody in the
world trust the swiss underneath streets
of zurich and lows an and geneva are
trillions of dollars from all around the
world and what i love about this place
is there's people here managing it see
all those houses all money managers
these guys there's thousands of them
make investments for people that put
their money into Switzerland all around
the world swiss franc the most coveted
currency in the world why the Swiss
never joined EU never joined the
eurozone didn't like the problems they
saw that's how smart they are they keep
themselves isolated but trusted and
they're fantastic money managers so
where are they putting their money
that's why I'm here I want to find out
this is a wonderful little village full
of money managers that invest globally I
asked them about Canada first are you
long Canada and their comments go like
this love Canada love the commodity
trade love everything about it love the
fact that Chinese want to own it but
it's only two and a half percent of the
world's gdp so we have to look elsewhere
to find growth where are they putting
their money I'm amazed to find out not
in the United States they're buying
Brazil India China South Korea Thailand
even Cambodia they love the growth the
Swiss love growth because their clients
want the growth and who are the clients
these days not Americans anymore Asians
the new story you can see see it
happening here is Asian money coming in
by that billions into Switzerland
absolutely fascinating the smell of
money till next time kevin O'Leary